هاله صدقي نجمه من سنين منوره الشاشات لكن
اللي جلسه بتعمله فينا السنوات الماضيه مو
عادي ابدا هذه السنه جرعه التالق مع عالم
الضعف كمان اكثر واكثر عملين بتشارك فيهم
هلا صدقي في رمضان في سره بدور ام السلطان
حامد اللي بيلعب دوره احمد السعدني
مشاهدها قليله لكن الدور ثقيل جدا ومؤثر
انا بقول لك انساها ياما مش عايز مش عايز
حامد مصيره معروف
في سره الباتع انه لو كان رئيسي كان اخذت
فيه جائزه افضل ممثله ومخرج العمل ومؤلف
وخالد يوسف قال انه عندها مشهد في الحلقه
الاخيره من العمل يخلد في تاريخها وتاريخ
السينما وهذا ردت وشكرته وقالت انها سعيده
بالتعامل مع مخرج محترف مثله اما الدور
الثاني لهذا صدقي واللي مكسر الدنيا في
حرفيا ومن اول حلقه فهو دور ام جعفر
العمده الست صف صف الست اللي دخلت قلوب
الناس من خفه دمها وكلامها اللي زي العسل
انت ور
ثته
[تصفيق]
ومعنا من القاهره النجم الملكه هلا صدقي
اهلا فيك معنا يا هلا وكل عام وانت بالف
خير ولا الملكه صفصف تحب نناديلك خلاص
الملكه
خلاص يعني وصلت القمه الان هلا ايش اللي
عملته فينا هذا رمضان انت اسطوره اسطوره
اسطوره اسطوره في هذا رمضان
الحمد لله يا رب يعني هو نمبر وان مين
هتخلفه يعني ملكه
فعلا
فعلا فعلا فعلا هتبقى امه حاجه مش عاديه
يعني ملكه تخلف نمبر وان تابعه يعني انت
انت متابعه الناس قديش بتتابع اللي
بتقوليه واللي بتسويه واللي بتعمليه
متابعه ردود الفعل
ردود الفعل وفي دراسه مسابقات على صفصف
وجرايد مهمه كاتبه اكتب مميزات صفصف قوي
احنا خمس اسباب انت حبيت صفصف ليه او قولي
عيوب صفصف يعني همم الحديث في ناس عايزين
يعملوا عرايس صفصف بس هو صفصف معندهاش
عيوب اصلا
لا طبعا لا طبعا دول مش فاهمين يعني بس
يعني هي يعني ده هي هي
بتتميز يا ساره
بالتواضع حقيقه نعم وانها عفيفه اللسان
وعفيفه اللسان
انا بقول لك ترى انا من اول لا انا من اول
رمضان انت ايقونتي واسطورتي خلاص صفصف هي
ايقونتي وعلى فكره انا امي اسمها صفيه
بقول لك انا امي كمان اسمها صفيه وادلعها
صفصفة يعني كمان ماشيه الامور تمام معانا
هلا محمد سامي قال انه اصلا قبل ما يكتب
الدور ده كان بيفكر فيك انت ايش معنى
ما اعرفش هو لقيته في يوم كده بيكلمني كنا
في الصيف قال لي بصي في دور كده في دماغي
وانا مش لاقي حد يعني مش بفكر انت بس اللي
قدامي مش مش اي حد ثاني
قولي لي دلوقتي اكتبه ولا لا قال لي انا
عندي مشكله انك ام لمحمد رمضان قلت له انا
عملت قبل كده امي لمحمد رمضان وعادي طبعا
قال لي لا في له اخ اكبر فانت سن اكبر
فقال لي دي المشكله الوحيده اللي عندي قلت
له دي بالنسبه لي مش مشكله خالص لان احنا
بالميك اب نقدر نعمل اي حاجه
وانا بالنسبه لي مش انا ممثله اعمل اي دور
بس هو الحقيقه الهدف كان عندي من زمان ان
انا عايزه اشتغل مع محمد سامي فانا هشبط
حتى لو عامل لي واحد عندها 100 سنه كنت
هعمله عشان محمد سامي
والتعامل مع محمد رمضان يعني زي ما انت
عارفه اوكي يلا
يعني قلنا
بدا يكتب بعث لي تريتمان قلت له حلو تمام
عملنا بروفات واشتغلنا الحمد لله
والتعامل مع محمد رمضان يعني انت عارفه كل
الاشياء اللي الناس بتقعد بتحكيها على
محمد رمضان وكده انت مثلا الان جثه بتقولي
انه لا نمبر وان وانا امه والملكه وكده
يعني واضح انه انسجمته فعليا
جدا وفي كميه قويه جدا بيني وبين رمضان
وبيني وبين محمد سامي ومحمد رمضان بيبقى
هو اصلا ممثل قوي لكن لما يبقى قدامه ممثل
قوي محمد رمضان بيضرب في عشره يعني انا
لاحظته في اعمال كثير ان محمد رمضان بيبقى
معاه ممثل ضعيف
بيقعد يشد يشد معه علشان يبقى على درجته
او على مستواه لكن محمد
يعني كل مواهبه بتبرز بجد لما يكون معه
ممثل قوي
بتختلف تماما بتزيد
لان هو اصلا ممثل بس الحلو في الاصل طيب
انا حابه بس نعرض خيرك كليب من
هو في اللوكيشن بصي يا ساره هو بني ادم
بسيط جدا متواضع جدا بيحب زمايله همم مش
اناني مش مش منافسن زي ما تقولي يعني في
ناس يقول لك الله دي احسن مني دي المشهد
بتاعها محمد رمضان مش كده محمد عايز كل
الناس كويسين ودي مواصفات النجم
النجم ده عايز كل الناس كويسه في كذا احد
وصفه هذا الوصف عشان
في بيت لكن في في في ممثلين او ودول
بيبقوا عمرهم قصير بيبقى هو اللي عايز
يظهر والباقي يموت حواليه انت قلتيها صح
ايوه محمد رمضان مش كده
جاي متناقش مع محمد سامي لو في اي حاجه
بيسمع كلام المخرج مش شايف ان المخرج هو
اللي له الكلمه اللي في الاخر اللي تقول
اه نعمل ده ان هو ده اللي شايف في نجوم
عندنا كتير قوي ممتازين لكن راحوا راحوا
في الوبا ليه لان تدخل في التصوير تدخل في
الانتاج تدخل في الاخراج بيموتوا تحبي
تسمي لنا اسامي يا هاله
لا طبعا لما اشوفك بقى
ههه
منتظراكي على نار طيب هاله خليني بس بدي
اعرض كليب ونرجع نتكلم
جايه لك جايه لك بكره
في المطار نستقبل نستقبل الماضي الملكه في
المطار خليني اشوف الكليب ونرجع
اه
لي احلى
مش كده
خلصتي يا جماعه
[تصفيق]
يا استاذه شرف والله العظيم
[موسيقى]
ملكه
ميرسي يا شباب يا حبيبي
[تصفيق]
يعني هم بيقولوا لك كان لنا الشرف نشتغل
معك تقولي لهم طبعا مستمره في اداء صفصف
يعني الاجابه طبعا
طب الكلام اللي بتقوليه هلا هذا كله كان
مكتوب في السيناريو
اغلبه اغلبه اه اغلبه يعني انا اضفت حاجات
بسيطه طبعا روحي وطريقه ادائي ااا
لكن طبعا في حاجات اه وفي حاجات هي اساسا
مكتوبه وفي حاجات اضافها محمد هو ده بقى
الكيمياء اللي بيني وبين محمد سامي في
اللوكيشن انه بنطلع حاجات هو بيطلع حاجات
وانا ساعات بطلع حاجات هو ساعات بيوافق
ساعات بيقول لي لا لان هو اللي شايف اكتر
في ساعات بنقول لكن هو في في المقبل طبعا
محمد سامي وانا طبعا في شويه تتشاط بتاعتي
طبعا
يعني اولادك ايش كانت رده فعلهم على
الانفجار هذا اللي صاير حوالين المسلسل
والله هم في الاول ما حسوش لغايه ما بقوا
العيال في المدرسه بيدوروا عليهم عايزين
يشوفوا اولاد صفصف ههه
حبايبي اتخض
والعيال بقى عايزين يصاحبوهم وعايزين
يجولهم البيت عايزين يتفرجوا على سفساف
وكده فالعيال قالوا لي العيال في المدرسه
يا مامي اختلفوا قوي وكله عايز يجي
يساحبنا وعاملين ويقولوا فين اولاد صفصف
ولاد صفصف ويعني
كانوا مخضوضين شويه لغايه ما قعدتهم شافوا
صفصف بقى وفهمه يعني لقوا عندهم زمايلهم
حافظين الديالوج وحافظين الحوار
اهتموا بقى بعد طب هلا انت يعني عامله
حاله خاصه في جعفر العمده بس بعدين اللي
بيقلب القناه مثلا او بيروح يشوف مسلسل سر
الباتع بيشوف هلا ثانيه مختلفه تماما هلا
يعني قمه في الاداء بس اداء يعني تراجيدي
ودرامي بحت كنت بتصوري في نفس الوقت ولا
يعني قديش صعب انه قدي كده الاختلاف ده
كنت للاسف بصور في نفس الوقت
وكنت بحاول افصل لان طبعا شخصيه صفصف كانت
مقصره علي قوي لغايه دلوقتي مقصره عليا
لكن طبعا انت كممثله لازم بتفصلي يعني انا
ما عملتش قصه ان انا اعمل عملين مع بعض في
وقت واحد ده من سنين طويله جدا انا بعمل
عمل واحد فقط في السنه
لكن طبعا فرصه ان خالد
يرجع ثاني يشتغل
وخلي يوسف انه ينزل تلفزيون اول مره انا
عارفه دي ممكن تبقى اخر مره لان عندنا في
البرنامج قال انه ما راح يكرر التجربه
شفتي اهو من غير ما اعرف ههه الاسبوع
الماضي كان ضيفنا وقال لا اخر مره
لا لانه خالد جه على نفسه قوي لانه هو
المفروض يبقى فيه مخرج معارك المخرج بتاع
مظاهرات وتحريك مجاميع
يعني المفروض يبقى معه بتاع اربع خمس
مخرجين للحاله اللي هو عاملها
الحقيقه الاستاذ خالد تحمل المسؤوليه كلها
يمكن لان طبعا انتاج مسلسل زي ده مش سهل
وما تعملش مسلسل تاريخي من ايام صلاح
الدين الايوبي وعلى التلفزيون كمان صعب
صعب
ومرتبط بوقت ومرتبط بمواعيد
والحكايه مش سهله يعني هو لما نزل نزل في
حاجه في منتهى الصعوبه
لكن طبعا دي كانت فرصه مش ممكن اضيعها
والحقيقه من من حلاوه الديالوج
والصوره اللي انا شفتها في الايام اللي
انا رحت فيها اصور كنت متضايقه جدا وعلى
المونيتور يعني انت حرمتنا عشر سنين من
الشغل ده لان احنا
مفتقدين ناس موهوبين حقيقيين على الشاشه
وقلت له انا لو كان دوري دور اساسي ورئيسي
في المسلسل انا متاكده ان انا كان لازم
اخد جائزه احسن ممثله بس هو كان ضيف شرفه
وده كان شرف كبير لي ان انا اشتغل في
مسلسل هلا احنا ما حسينا انك ضيفه شرف
انا بتابع المسلسل انا ما حسيت انك ضيفه
شرف لانك محرك رئيسي
بصي هو لما يبقى 15 حلقه في 30 حلقه يبقى
ضيف شرف اوكي بس انت لان يمكن دور ام احمد
السعدني والمشاهد كانت مؤثره جدا صراحه
بس هو ضيف شرف للاسف طب على العموم انت
يعني انت في اي شيء حتى لو عملتي مشهد لو
عملتي مشهد واحد انت نجمه انت الملكه صفصف
برضه يعني في نهايه اليوم بس ربنا يخليك
طبعا طبعا طيب هلا السنه الماضيه نحن كان
عندنا لقاء وقت مسلسل فاتن امل حربي وانت
كنت وقتها برضه مكسر الدنيا في هذا الدور
واتكلمنا في موضوع وقتها حابه اذكرك فيه
خلينا نشوف الكليب ونرجع نتكلم
اذا انت اللي بتتكلمي عنه كمان يعني جزء
منه شيء شخصي انت مريتي فيه
طبعا انا لسه
لسه بمر فيه لسه شغاله يعني الحمد لله
انا بصي المسلسل هيخلص مسلسل مش هيخلص
ان شاء الله
[ضحك]
انا واضح انه 120 حلقه انا مكمله شويه في
جزء ثاني ثالث وكده ان شاء الله ربنا ما
يقطعها عادي يا حبيبتي
[ضحك]
هلا المسلسل انتهى
احنا طبعا بنتكلم عن قصه طلاقك وسنين
طويله موضوع الطلاق طبعا
بصي انت وشك حلو عليا بس لانه انا انا
طبعا مش عايزه اقول لك انا تعبانه ومجهده
قد ايه لاني انا من الساعه 8:00 الصبح في
الشارع وطبعا نازله من سته ونايمه خمسه
لانه احنا الحمد لله الحمد لله الحمد لله
الطلاق تم
خلص الموضوع الحمد لله
والنهارده بالتحديد
رحت غيرت اسمي في الرقم القومي همم الاي
دي بتاعي يعني وغيرت الباسبور وغيرت كل
الاوراق يعني كل الاوراق القديمه اترمت
والنهارده كل اوراق جديده الحمد لله خلاص
نقدر نزغرط لك الان على الهواء يعني
اذا انت بتعرفي تصغرطي
الطلاق تم من اربع شهور او ثلاث شهور بس
برضو
يعني يعني يمكن ده يا ساره اداني طاقه في
الشغل يعني
اكيد اكيد لانه كان في حمل في في دماغك
شغاله في حاجات تانيه مش قادره تركزي
يمكن
والحمد لله النهارده اوراقي كلها جديده
ممتاز الف مبروك دبي باوراق الله الله
حياه جديده وشخصيه جديده يعني يعني فعلا
فعلا هلا انت كنت شاقمه جدا في السنه
الماضيه قلت انا مسلسل ما راح يخلص
اه بس سبحان الله شوفي كيف سنه فرجت بس
الحمد لله الحمد لله ما عندكيش عريس يا
ساره
ههه
هل انت ناويه تعيديها
شريط يا ناويه تعيديها ناويه تكرر التجربه
المفروض الدرس كان صعب شويه النهارده بنتي
النهارده
لا لا بنتي النهارده عماله تزن عليا في
القصه دي طولها بس يا ماما بس يا حبيبتي
لا لا الحمد لله الحمد لله
ربما انك خلاص ما تبقي عريس احنا منتظرينك
في دبي تجينا وتنورينا
والملكه صفصف وحنطبل لك وحنسوي لك كل
الاشياء اللي بتحبيها هلا يعني وعايزه
سجاد احمر ولا يهمك ولا يهمك
طلبات صغيره دي يا هاله طلبات صغيره جدا
مش من قيم جايه لكم بتهزري يا ساره طبعا
ملكه جايه لك يا ماما ايه بقى اكيد لا انت
هتنورينا هلا انا اتعب وانا اقول لك انت
قديش نجمه هذا الرمضان انت اللي عاملاه في
سر الباتع وجعفر العمده فعليا شيء فوق
الخيال عدا عن انه انا بشكل عام اصلا انا
احبك يعني
كمشاهده انا احبك انت وشخصيتك وكل شيء فيك
يعني وادائك وكل حاجه يعني
فقلوب من دبي الى القاهره الى انت تجينا
ان شاء الله على دبي ونشوفك وننبسط بشوفتك
شكرا لك يا هلا على وقتك اليوم ان شاء
الله ميرسي يا ساره اشكرك ميرسي ميرسي
[موسيقى]